-Hey, guys, it is Tuesday.
It's time for "WeTweet".
Here we go.
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet".
This is where we,
as a group, decide something
that we should post on Twitter.
I'm gonna show you five
different tweets,
and we're all gonna vote on
whether you like
each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
You can vote for all of them,
you can vote for none of them,
whatever you want.
We're gonna see the results
live.
Higgins, Roots, you guys have
your clickers?
-Mm, yes.
-All right, whatever tweet
gets the most likes,
we will tweet it out live
on the show so you can all like
it and WeTweet it.
-[ Audience ] Ohh.
-It's a shared experience.
All right, are you guys ready
for this?
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-All right,
the first tweet is...
-Oh, tepid.
-Tepid reaction.
-Yeah.
-This is the first mask-less
"WeTweet".
-Well, yeah, I got
a decent laugh up top
and then dive -- fizzled.
-Then dipped -- dive.
-Yeah, yeah, but I understand
where they're coming from.
All right, let's see.
Everyone done?
The votes are in, let's see
the results on this one.
-Ooh.
-Yeah, yeah, that's okay.
Half and half.
Half and half, good.
I appreciate the honesty.
Thank you, everyone.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-Yeah.
-This next one here is...
[ Cheering ]
I mean, it's, like, so close.
It's this close.
It's like, "Ooh, another."
Come on, just move the table.
All right, here we go.
This one, I feel pretty good
on this one.
Let's see the results
-Whoa!
♪♪
-That's it.
That's a wrap.
-Don't go for humor,
just go for truth.
-Yeah.
-Preach.
Preach. 194, man.
-That was both truthful
and humorous.
-Yeah, might be a world record,
194.
-Is it?
-Yeah.
-I think we can beat it.
I think we can beat it.
-Are you serious?
-Yeah, I think we can beat it.
-I believe you.
-I'm not sure
if this one's the one
but maybe.
-Yeah, not this week, but.
-The next one here says...
[ Light laughter ]
-[ Laughs ] Tahini.
-[ Laughs ]
Just say yes just to be nice.
-Come on!
-I know you don't
have to say it, just --
come on, Tarik.
-I did, I did.
-Tahini. Tee-hee.
-Tee-hee-hee.
-Tahini.
-All right, let's see
the results here.
-Oh.
-Oh, my goodness.
Wow, terrible.
No one liked that one at all.
Wow.
-Awful.
-Forget that ever happened.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
This will be all cut out.
-Let's check out the next
one here.
This one says...
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Come on.
-Think about it.
-Yeah.
-Makes sense.
Everybody's just waving.
-...friends.
-All right, yeah, I think
this one's gonna do okay.
It's not gonna beat 194, though.
-It's gonna be dece.
-Yeah, 'cause I can tell,
'cause the audience would
kind of still be laughing.
-Right, but they're not.
-No.
Right now it's dead silence,
yeah.
-Mouthbrow.
-They've had enough.
They liked that one, but let's
see the results anyway.
Here we go.
Oh, not bad!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Not bad.
-Wow.
-Still, iPhone charger's
the one.
-Not 194.
-The iPhone chargers
in the hotel room is the one
so far,
but this is the one, right here,
I think might shatter
the record.
-You serious?
-Maybe. It might -- yeah.
-Game.
-I'm ready.
-But it's up to you guys, yeah.
-Yes, right now.
-Well, I didn't say it, yeah.
-I have that much faith in you.
-All right, thank you.
This last one is...
[ Laughter ]
-Come on!
We can beat it.
If we can beat 194...
-Come on, we can beat 194.
Just like the dog to go,
"Hey, you know what?
You're a good boy."
-Yeah.
-Finally, you -- yeah,
you know who's a good boy?
You are, yeah.
All right, I feel good
about this.
I feel good.
-I'm saying yes.
-I don't know.
Let's see the results.
Here we go. Beat 194.
-Oh!
-Aw!
-It does not.
-Number two is
the correct tweet --
the iPhone charger, still,
had 194.
-Oh!
[ Bell dings ]
-Every hotel room needs
an iPhone charger
that reaches the bed.
I'm gonna post this
during the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like.
Give it a WeTweet and enjoy.